فرحه ومرحب
دجاجات جاري عندي مشكله صراحه كبيره معهم
اليوم
في حلول
طبعا
اللي لها حل ابداعي بدي اياكم ترفعوا
الكرت الاخضر اللي عنده حل فعلا مبدع
فقولي كرت الاخضر
شهرين سالنا كثير ناس اعطونا حلول اعطونا
حلول اعطونا حلول
وصراحه طلعت افكار حلوه منيحه اعتياديه
ممكن تحل المشكله
وطلعت شويه افكار جنونيه بصراحه انا شخصيا
ممكن تنحل
انه ممكن يطبقوا هذا الحل فعليا ويطبق بس
فعليا افكار جنونيه لو تطبقت وانحلت راح
تغير الدنيا
عشان المجانين الذين يعتقدون
انهم يستطيعون تغيير العالم هم يفعلون ذلك
الي بيعتقد انه المجانين هم يغيرون العالم
لو سمحتوا افتحوا افتحوا الكروت بتاعتكم
وطلعوا الكرت الاخضر واللي بيعتقد انه
العاقلين هم من يستطيعون تغيير العالم
ارفعوا الكارت الاحمر
حلو في تقريبا 50 50
بس بصراحه وفي ناس ما رفع ولا كارت بصراحه
يا احمد موضوع الكوت وكذا وهذا ما رفعت
عشان انا بصراحه مش فاهم شو تعريف مجنون
يعني شو تعريف المجانين
خليني اعرفكم
على بانه
بلكي ساعدتنا في هذا التعريف بس قبل ما
اعرفكم عليها بدي اياكم تفكروا ايش في
مشاكل موجوده عندكم في المجتمعنا مشاكل في
المنطقه اللي انتم فيها في القريه في
المدينه في البيت اللي موجوده بلكي باخر
هال 20 دقيقه نقدر نوصل لحل
بانه بنتي من اول من ولدت فيها زي كل
الاطفال وخلينا نسميها نقطه الصفر
كان عندها قدره تسوي اشياء جنونيه اشياء
يعني ما بقدر حدا يفكر فعلا ممكن نطبقها
زيي
تحاول توقف
بجنيه الضعاف
ومعينهم 100 مره بس برده مره ثانيه
وعبر السنوات بتبلش الافكار الجنونيه
بتزيد
لبانه ام السبع سنين ونصف تقولي بابا بدي
بدي اطلع مصاري زيك بدي لو سمحت اعمل خدمه
على موضوع خدمه رعايه الاطفال بس الصغار
رايح على الشغل مريت من البنك اللي جنب
بيتنا بالحاره ولايه الاعلان موجود طبعا
انا ايش بلشت بدي الف الف بالحاره كلها
اشوفها موجوده
المجنون تعريفه هو العاقل
العاقل اللي مستوعب انه الفشل في تجربه مش
معناها والله
بدي استسلم ولا معناها كرر نفس الموضوع
ولكن معناها جرب مره اخرى في مكان اخر
وبطريقه اخرى
يا ترى كيف ممكن
هذا التعريف يساعدنا نحل مشاكل المجتمعنا
وكمان صلاح يحل لي مشكله الدجاجات مع جاري
طبعا
بعد ما خلصنا اجبانه تقول لي بابا خلص
يعني بدي هلا ابيع بالشارع بره شويه العاب
قلت يا حبيبي انتقل من العائله وبدها تطلع
لوين للحدود الخارجيه تبلش تبيع في
الاسواق المحليين بلاش تقول لها انه لحظه
لحظه
انزلي بس قدام البيت
والله نص ساعه بابا بابا بيعت كل الالعاب
ب 11 دينار وعشان انك ساعدتنا هي دينار
والله
والله هي الدينار خليته معي قالت لي شكرا
لك
المجنون هو العاقل
اللي ما بخلي عقله محدد بمحددا وهميه مش
موجوده
احل مشاكل دجاجات جاري
خلي نجرب نفس الحدود
تفتحوا الدفتر تبعكم وترسمه تسعه نقاط
بهذا الشكل
وبدي اياكم تحوله
ضغط وهذه التسعه نقاط باستخدام اربع خطوط
مستقيمه
متصله
بدون ما تشيله يدكم ودومه
اربع خطوط مستقيمه
متصله
ترسموها بدون ما تشيل القلم على الورقه
وبدون ما ترجع نفس الخط
اللي قدر
يحلها معكم شويه وقت بس ارفعوا لي الكرت
الاخضر خليني اشوف الدين النسبه هيك
الموجوده في المجموعه
بدون ما اشيل يدي واشيل القلم من الورقه
فكر خارج الصندوق وايش المحدد اللي بدي
اكسره
الكرت الاخضر
في عندنا حوالي عشره تقريبا
هاي المشكله
المحدد اللي بيجي اكسره هو القاضي لو كسرت
المحدد انه ما بيصير اطلع عن التسعه نقاط
راح اغطي التسع نقاط بالاربع خطوط
تحدي اخر
بدياكم
ثلاث خطوط برده بنفس الاسلوب مستقيمه
متصله ببعض
برده خذوا 30 ثانيه
واسالوا حالكم ايش الحدود الوهميه اللي
جوه عقلي ايش طريقه تفكير بانه اللي ممكن
يساعدني احل هذه المشكله
واحل
مشكله المجتمع لنا فيه القريه اللي انا
فيه الجامعه اللي انا فيها مشكله دجاجات
المحدد الموجود عندي
اذا كسرت المحدد انه ما مش لازم هل لازم
الخط يكون متوازي مع النقاط ولا بقدر اسوي
زاويه خفيفه بحيث اتخلى عن احد الخطوط
حلو كسرنا الحدود طيب التحدي الاخير
غطولي التسعه نقاط بخط واحد الله اكبر
اللي مخليني مش قادر افكر بهذا الحل موجود
والله مجتمعاتنا قرانا جمعتنا فيها مشاكل
وفيها حلول ولكن بس اكسر المحددات الوهميه
لو استطعت اكسر المحدد انه هل لازم الخط
يكون نحيف او لا
لا لا لا يا احمد
طيب بلاش اقول لكم شغله سووها بخط واحد
باستخدام القلم وهي كمان فكره
اكسره الحدود
وفعليا لقيتها واقفه وبلشت تحكي
العاب بدينار
طبعا هون انا قلت لحظه شويه ايش اللعبه
اللي بالدينار اللي طلعتها طلعت ايش عامله
تعريف المجنون هو العاقل اللي
بيستغل موارد المتاحه اللي ما بيخلي قله
الموارد الموجوده عندنا تكون عائق
للابتكار والابداع بالعكس بتكون شراره
عشان يفكر بطريقه مختلفه ويبدا بطريقه
مختلفه ونطلع الحلول تبعتنا من الرحم
مشكلتنا وهذا بيسموه الخروج بالحلول من
عالمنا المغلقه
العماره اللي قدامكم هاي
فيها درج والمشكله في اختياريه بهاي
العماره وما في اصنصير وبتعبوا كثير بين
كل طابق وطابق ايش في حل ممكن نلاقيه مش
مكلفه
ما نفكر في حلول مقلقه
من خلال عالمنا المغلق ما وردنا المتاحه
اللي بالصوره هنا فكوا فيها ايش ممكن اسوي
الي بقول بدي اشتري كرسي ممكن ولكن مقرف
ولكن مجتمعاتنا يمكن ما عندها القدره على
موضوع ان انا ادور واصرف هاي المبالغ
فكر فيها اللي لقى حل مبتكر بس ارفعون
للكرت الاخضر
اللي مقدر انه ما في حل ارفع الكرت الاحمر
الحل
والتالي
استغل مواردي اللي هي سبب المشكله في الحل
اغير الدرابزين شوي بحيث يتحول لكرسي
للختياريه كل طابق يقعدوا يرتاح
ايش في مشاكل بمجتمعنا حسين المستحيل
نحلها ايش في مشاكل في جامعتنا بقريتنا
بمنطقتنا لا مستحيل يكون اله حل الا
بالمصاريف ايش في مشاكل ممكن نحلها
المغلقه ضمن مواردنا المتاحه
نرجع له
دجاجات جاري جاري
في حلول مختلفه ومتنوعه من ضمن العالم
المغلق من ضمن مواردنا زي مثلا ممكن
الرشاش الموجود هنا اركب عليه سنسر فاول
ما يحس بحركه الجاجات يبلش يشتغل
وممكن مثلا احكي ولا بدي اجيب النباتات
الشوكيه الموجوده واصرحها حوالين الخضار
شوي بحيث اسوي زي بركه واعبيها تراب واحط
الخضار
وممكن افكر انا وجاري واقول له اسمع طيب
الف صحه عليهم ياخذوا الخضار هاي وكل يوم
اعطيني بيت بلدي برضه
وبالنهايه ممكن اذبح حجاجات واعزم جاري
على كبس الخضار وخلصت الامور ومشي امورك
ولا الخضار ولا هم العاقل هو المجنون
ام المجنون هو العاقل
المجنون هو العاقل
اللي مستعد
يحارب المحددات العقليه
هو مستعد يحارب المحددات الوهميه هو
المستعد يستغل موارد المتاحه لعالم المغلق
عشان لاقي حلول
المتاحه كيف ممكن فعلا نوصل لحل ولكن
الغريب انه سمع عن سنه بتبطل لان هذه
القدره الرائعه او بمعنى اخر نتربى
وبنتعلم
بحيث تختفي او تتغطى هاي القدره غير عاديه
سؤال لكم اليوم
هل مستعدين نجرب ونكسر المحددات الوهميه
ونرجع
لنقطه الصفر نقطه بانه
اللي هي نقطه التفكير خارج السرب
فكروا فيها شكرا جزيلا
[تصفيق]
على صاحبه الافكار العظيمه بنبوري
هون الافكار هون الافكار العظيمه
[تصفيق]